we've got a surprise for you a live
satellite interview on location with one
of the hottest new stars of the year
from hog farm its babe on behalf of
moviegoers all over the world we
congratulate you for your work I can't
tell you how grateful I am be off well
we're grateful also a whoopie baby I
can't hear you are you there
oh my goodness it seems like was
temporarily lost our uplink babe all
right
yeah that's what I'm up lay down
well Miss Piggy oh what a surprise
did someone call for a babe
actually I was just talking to babe well
that was then this is now
ah you know you're probably right I
don't need to really talk to anybody
else because you after all are the
biggest pig and shell business well
thank you would be dear thank you
there's a lot of competition now it's
tough for a mature pig to get work these
days Donna I know it all right now that
I'm on the show how would you like me to
save it with my unique brand of stuff
over listen Miss Piggy I think the
satellites about to pass I will close
with one of those sensational production
numbers I could work on us you see Miss
Piggy and they're telling me we can
reconnect with a Hoggett farm now ladies
and gentlemen please a big hand for the
one and only
thank God Miss Piggy Thank You Whoopi
whatever yes getting Whoopi can you see
me well that's I can't really are you
there
Oh Oh beautifully done thank you listen
we're starting to lose you again so we
better say good night okay give my
regards to the boss oh you're a
Springsteen fan farmer Hoggett music I
see well good night babe